foreign
[Music]
don't leave the old road for a new Trail
don't bite off more than you can chew
the tongue has no bone but it cuts
through the thickest material
a good payer will not object to leaving
a deposit
don't judge a book by its cover
only those who risk going far can find
out how far they can go
let foolish words fall on deaf ears
[Music]
love is not to look at each other is to
look together in the same direction
[Music]
every moment is a fresh beginning
it always seems impossible until it's
done
Don't Drown yourself in a glass of water
[Music]
what life offers you and try to drink
from every cup
God helps those who get up early
Never Say Never limits like fears are
often Just an Illusion
if you fall seven times get up eight
[Music]
the shrimp Who falls asleep is taken by
the current
[Music]
the one who is near a good tree will be
well shaded
whoever sows the wind reaps a storm
[Music]
that one who has the most isn't the
richest but the one who needs the least
do good and don't look at the one you're
helping
foreign
from the past live in the present and
work for the future
the door hangs longest
don't cry because it's over smile
because it happened
[Music]
love conquers all
a Fool's money doesn't last
where there's no flower everything is an
annoyance
[Music]
there is no worse deaf person than he
who refuses to hear
how nice it is to see the rain and not
get wet
to govern is to foresee
where there's smoke there's fire
the root of all evil is the Love of
Money
Time Heals all
if you act like you know what you're
doing you can do whatever you want
nothing ventured nothing gained
When in Rome do as the Romans do
love is finding in someone else's
happiness your own
learn from other people's mistakes
four eyes see more than two
actions speak louder than words
call a speed a speed
to love without suffering is impossible
[Music]
there is no bad job the bad thing is not
having a job
All That Glitters Is Not Gold
[Music]
I haven't failed I've just found
solutions that didn't work
the truth comes out sooner or later
[Music]
if you're hungry there is no hard bread
curiosity killed the cat
every master has his own trick
love me when I least deserve it that is
when I need it most
[Music]
out of sight out of mind
better late than never
loose lips sink ships
[Music]
don't look a gift horse in the mouth
brains win over brawn
you catch more flies with honey than
vinegar
[Music]
favor with favor
every crazy person has their issue
[Music]
lock the Barn Door after the horse has
bolted
to even the best scribe comes a smudge
[Music]
the face is the mirror of the Soul
not every truth should be said
from speech to deed there is a good
stretch
success comes when your dreams exceed
your excuses
walls have ears
[Music]
the secret of life is not always doing
what you want but always wanting what
you do
foreign
if the water is undrinkable let it run
a bird in the hand is worth more than a
hundred in flight
if there is a deal even a dog and cat
can be friends
when the cat goes to his devotions the
rats dance
speaking of the king of Rome there he is
at the door
don't leave for tomorrow what you can do
today
the lion is not as Fierce as he is made
out to be
the art of winning is learned through
losing
to wash a pig with soap is to lose time
and soap
He who reads a lot and walks a lot sees
a lot and knows a lot
you are The Company You Keep
the good path is narrow the
self-indulgent one is wide
the man who stands up after falling is
greater than the one who hasn't fallen
where there is desire there is ability
Beggars can't be choosers
the truth may be stretched thin but not
broken
it's by doing an undoing that we learn
the beauty that attracts rarely matches
the beauty that makes you fall in love
what's done is done
smile at life and it will return your
smile
don't sell the bears hide before you
hunted
don't waste energy crying over yesterday
or dreaming about tomorrow
the reason the family is poor is because
the parents work hard and the children
only enjoy life as a result the
grandchildren are engaged in begging
great trees spring from Tiny seeds
don't pay back kindness pass it on
[Music]
never give up on a dream just because of
the time it will take to accomplish it
time will pass
[Music]
forgiving is not forgetting forgiving is
remembering without pain
[Music]
life is measured in the moments that
leave you Breathless
each of us will have to make the choices
that allow us to be the greatest
versions of ourselves
your great strength is knowing who you
are
[Music]
to stay young keep learning
thank you
[Music]